hello everyone and welcome to magnus
carlsen vs. Levin harden the only game
we haven't seen from round 8 of the 2013
candidates tournament but before we
start with the game we do have one pop
quiz question so here this I will just
show it to you and I hope you
immediately know what it is so here it
is now I hope at least 50% of you know
that those were the standing the final
standings of the 1959 candidates
tournament and the why are you seeing
this now we'll get back to this after
the game and we do have a couple of
photos from this round here we have a
photographer's photographing Carlson and
Ariane is just arriving at the board
here another photo of photographers
photographing Costin Aragon those two
are the leaders in round 8 and of course
everyone wants a photo of them that
photo will of course gets get the most
clicks so it makes perfect sense here we
have a nice photo from the opening and
well there's nothing all about the photo
Aaron does have a thermos bottle stashed
to the to the right of him and we do
have a nice photo of course and in Gelf
under staring at obviously what what
appears to be someone's position perhaps
even chokes but you know we can never
know so I do hope you enjoyed those now
let's see this game c4 so Carlson opens
the game with the English Knight to f6
we have Knight to f3 let me just dim
that sound so I don't have double sounds
as I didn't make that blunder in a
couple of other videos east 6g 3 and the
d5 Bishop to g2 Bishop to e7 d4 we have
castles castles and the D captures on c4
Queen to c2 attacking the c4 pawn and
here we have a 6 you could defend this
would be 5 but you can never really
defend it so I for newer players I would
I would if you already capturing on c4
in any variation you definitely don't
want to
and it would be five you'll only get
into trouble a white will always
undermine this with a four and then if
you insist on defending it to then
simply white will capture and you will
get into a lot of trouble for example
now there's an open attack from the
bishop to your rook and there's there's
really no way to prevent Bishop captures
rook so whatever you play you're gonna
be down the exchange so hope that a
little bit of information was useful for
you in the game a six was played by our
renowned we have Queen captures on c4 b5
and Queen back to C - Bishop to b7
Bishop to d2 Bishop to d6 a3 Knight B to
d7 and B for now and here our onion
could go for for let's say an
adventurous move would be 5 and after
captures D captors on e5 Knight captures
let's say Bishop to c3 and now Bishop to
e4 attacking the Queen it would be an
interesting position but it's it's very
thoroughly analyzed and there's really
nothing here for either side so Aragon
came prepared for this game he plays a
very strong engine line he plays rook to
a7 and this is very strong cousin
continuous with Knight to c3 Queen to a8
and immediately calls and exchanges the
light square Bishop Knight to h4 Bishop
captures Knight captures and now c6 if
you're interested there will be a link
in the description below where you can
check out an interview from the press
conference
you know there's cost in its answers to
a couple of questions then our own
answers a couple of questions they
discuss this c6 move Carlson says that
he never really even considered this
move and Aaron says that well he was
prepared with this move and there's that
there's really nothing for white here so
rook a to C 1 we have a five nine three
four and now Knight to e4 Queen captures
on e4 and now rook to c8 Knight to f4
may be threatening Knight captures and
e6 and some variations but definitely
not to momentarily a capture some before
and now of course you do have to
at least check can you capture on e6 if
you can maybe it would be a good idea of
course in this position I hope all of
you see that it doesn't work I mean
maybe maybe black could even capture the
night but he doesn't even have to he can
simply go rook here simply pin tonight
and here you would grab a couple of
points for your piece but after rook
captures rook captures rook to see a
check and Bishop captures and before
Bishop captures pawn captures you would
for example have to port the two points
for the piece but in the long run by
black would win this endgame so after a
capture some before who has Bishop
captures and before a capture some
before doesn't really doesn't really
work black will easily infiltrate and
then white could only only get in
trouble so after I capture some before
Bishop capture some before was played c5
now Queen captures on a8 rook captures
an a8 and phone captures on c5 Bishop
captures and now Knight to d3 Bishop to
f8 rook captures rook captures and now
rook to be one either Bishop will
capture and then after rook captures the
rook will already be attacking the beep
on or Bush will capture and and well
Carson would definitely like enjoy
capturing the b-pawn but rook to e8 now
if the bishops come off the board and
the a pawn will come under attack Bishop
capture screen captures and now Carlsen
there's really no better move to play
here so here at Carlson simply captures
the pawn rook captures and now we have
g4 h 6h 4 and rook to a2 and if you look
at this position if you remember from
round one where Aragon had the white
pieces it's a pretty similar position to
the one hand they had in round 1 of the
2013 candidates tournament the one if
you remember when the were the pawns
shaped a heart not really drawing a
heart here but it was in the thumbnail
so maybe you remember it so it's even
possible to create such a position from
here but they don't go for it they play
King f1 rock checks King goes back Rock
a 2 and here
in its it was around this position
because the players don't really
remember at which point that this was
Aragon offered the draw but the cross
and actually refused the draw in this
position he said he refused it for no
reason he just thought it was maybe a
good idea to play on
so King to f3 now rook to a3 King to g3
or okay - III rook to d2 Knight to f4 g6
g5 there's really nothing to do here
captures captures King g7e for rook to
c2 f3 rook c5 rook captures Knight
captures and after night the g2 finally
in this position on unmoved 41 so the
time control has been reached they
decided to draw this game so yeah that's
you know it's not the most exciting game
but I mean it's a very strong game
between two leaders of the tournament
even though at the time this game was
played the commentators did kind of call
it a snoozefest but that's exactly the
reason why i shown why i've shown you
the final standings of the 1959
candidates tournament here as you can
see and of course because of your vast
knowledge you'll notice because i'll won
the tournament with 20 points ahead of
paul Kara's he had he was one and a half
point ahead of Paul Karras while he
didn't actually have good results
against Paul Karras see her here you can
see that Carson and Aragon drew both of
their games and in the in the 1959
candidates tournament Karras even had a
positive result against Michael Tao
but Michael Tao had better results
against some of the weaker players in
the tournament so it's something that
will usually happen in the tournament
you will not necessarily beat the one
who is trying to you know catch up to
you but rather you will just beat you
will you know beat the weaker players
more severely so that's that's why I
thought it was a it was a nice
comparison to show this and it's always
nice to remember the final standings of
the 1959 candidates tournament so yeah
and after after seeing all this with all
the photos now we it's time to check out
standings after round 8 of the 2013
candidates tournament so here it is we
have caution and Arnon still tied in
first place five and a half points both
Vladimir Kramnik is now in third place
after his victory over over over Peter
Svidler with four and a half then we
have Grisha with for engagement after
his very nice victory with
three-and-a-half sweedler once again
with three and a half Rajab with three
and lastly one with two and a half
points still in last place so yeah with
this we conclude around eight of the
2013 candidates tournament I do hope you
enjoyed it and tomorrow we return to
this tournament with round 9 and some
very interesting games photos and
hopefully stories so as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon with another game thank you